All right, let's go back to the phones at
six one seven eight three zero forty 50 and
see what is on people's minds.
A lot going on.
We will next try our caller from the seven
one three area code.
Who's calling today from seven one three?
Where are you calling from?
Hello, David, this is James.
I'm from Houston, Texas.
What's going on, James?
Oh, yeah.
So to preface this, I'm kind of in between
the two third parties, I'm kind of undecided
between the Green Party, Howard Hawkins and
the Libertarian Party.
And this pick, like I have read, progressive
social views and things like that, as well
as economic views.
But this pick for Kamala Harris just really
I was I was kind of on the Biden train, but
now I'm I'm really going to I'm really convinced
I have to vote for Hawkins.
He's also got a black running mate, Angela
Walker.
But I just don't think Kamala Harris is the
right pick.
She's.
She feels like such a view to the African-American
community as well.
OK.
So what?
So so what can you say more about that?
What was what is it exactly her record as
California attorney general is what's concerning
you?
That's why you might not vote for Biden.
Harris.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm obviously I don't like Trump,
really, I don't even like Biden that much,
but just her record.
And also I was kind of on the tulsi see, I
was kind of a big supporter, supporter of
Tulsi.
And the only thing that brought Kamala Harris
kind of back into the spotlight was Joe Biden
kind of defending her and then saying that
he will keep her as a pick for his V.P..
Okay.
But does that have anything to do with why
you would or wouldn't vote for her, for them?
Yeah, I just I just don't think it's a.
Of it's not she's she's a she's a warhawk
to the drug war, you're and I don't think
any of this system that was made and accelerated
in the 90s under the presidency of Bill Clinton
really needs to continue anymore.
And has she said that it would continue?
Well, I mean, I just don't I mean, Beau Biden
doesn't want to legalize marijuana.
That's true.
No, he doesn't.
I just don't feel that a four, four or 12
years of Biden and Harris.
I know I'm not saying it's going to be that
way, but I just don't feel like stuff is going
to change as much socially on these on these
economic issues as well.
Because this.
Well, hold on a second, let's back up radar.
But we also, because of the war on drugs,
I have to stop you there, if anything, over
the last three weeks, the divide on economic,
remember, it's Biden versus Trump, right.
So Kamala Harris, his economic ideas from
from three years ago are not what is going
to determine what the next four look like.
A huge chasm or chiasm has opened up between
Biden and Trump on economic policy.
I mean, Trump wants to cut the payroll tax,
which funds Social Security, whereas Biden
wants to uncap it above 400000 dollars.
That that's like ninety nine to one difference
on capital gains.
Trump wants to cut capital gains.
Biden wants to tax capital gains as ordinary
income.
I mean, I could go on, but on economic policy,
you know, whatever your views are on Harris,
we.
There is nothing similar about Biden and Trump
on that issue at this point.
And to say there is is very deceptive.
Oh, I totally support Biden on the economic
issues, it's just the social issues.
Okay.
I mean, let me ask you this.
Let's just bottom line.
But bottom line it.
Do you do you prefer Biden or Trump to be
president if it's going to be one of the two?
Because it is going to be one of the two.
Who do you prefer?
Oh, definitely Biden.
Okay, so then maybe a vote for Biden.
OK, yeah.
I mean, I still I'll still do a little bit
of research, but thanks for it.
Thanks for answering my call, David.
OK.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thanks very much.